the haze is back outside although i
really think it'll be thicker for
tomorrow we'll show you that in just a
bit right now notice though we do have
mainly clear skies 107 degrees our
official high for the day today that was
still above the average like it's been
lately
record was 113 that was set back last
year we reached 113
on this date last year 107 centennial
hills same for you in sky canyon spring
valley 104 106 north las vegas these are
above normal temperatures and on top of
that we have humidity between 15 to 20
percent 107 for winning ranch 105 for
henderson mountains edge and also road
ranch you're currently 104 and we'll
always switch up our neighborhoods we'll
have new neighborhoods here to show you
coming up at 6 30. 105 for prep right
now indian springs you're at 102 boulder
city 104 laughlin checking in at 108 in
fact there are still heat alerts in
effect right now not for las vegas but
for lincoln county all the way over to
nye county too and over to inyo county
that should expire though at 8 pm as the
numbers will be dropping each day
as we will see a slight cooling trend
valley radar dry here a few spots of
showers in the mountains nothing too big
at all in fact as we zoom out look at
mohave county not as active as yesterday
most of the storms are down in phoenix
we often flagstaff so really the
storms are fewer than what we saw
yesterday and we'll get lesser coverage
as we get through this week why well
here's our futurecast first not
expecting any storms for tonight but
what we'll see coming from the pacific
northwest is a trough it'll be diving
down through the southern great basin
into our area too and that'll give us a
drier westerly flow now wednesday we
still could see some isolated
thunderstorms east county maybe eastern
portions of lincoln county and certainly
in arizona but we should be drier these
next few days and certainly as we get
through the second half of the week and
into your weekend as a trough still
remains in place so here's the forecast
87 overnight mostly clear and hazy
thicker smoke expected for tomorrow
unfortunately 106 for tomorrow hazy and
breezy we could see those gusts up to 30
tomorrow especially by the afternoon
here's your eight on the eight forecast
that haze for tomorrow breezy winds
still continue on hump day and then
notice your numbers start to drop too
look at that as we head into your
weekend
plenty of sunshine and next week we'll
be right back to those triple digits
again that's your most accurate forecast
denise how are you